what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime All Pro and today we will be
talking about a new epic battle that has
just commenced between Mele Otis and the
demon king and about the very clear
clues which suggest that Arthur and
Excalibur will return in the seven
deadly sins story clues that are based
directly on our 13 legend I can't wait
to get into this there is a lot to talk
about so let's do it if you enjoy the
seven deadly sins content on this
channel you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to anime or don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell also in case you don't
know we are on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproars so feel free to follow us
for all the latest updates finally there
will be manga spoilers in this video we
are dealing with the latest developments
in the seven deadly sins story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned on the very first page of chapter
314 we actually got a pretty massive
clue about what is going to happen later
on in the story but in order to
understand the importance of this first
page you have to be familiar with
Arthurian legend the first page says the
magic lake in salisbury located 10 miles
to the west of camelot is believed to be
the most magically enriched site in all
of britannia legend has it that the
princess who lives in the lake bestowed
a mysterious sword to a human king in
some versions of the Arthurian legend
the Lady of the lake is a woman who
lives in a lake and she was the one who
gave Arthur the legendary sword
Excalibur the fact that we just saw a
glimpse of Arthur in the previous
chapter and now we are being told of a
princess who lives in a magical lake the
same woman who in Arthurian legend was
the one who gave Excalibur to King
Arthur all of this is a clear indication
that Arthur is coming back as I said in
the previous video before the seven
deadly sins story ends Arthur and
Excalibur will play some kind of
important role after all of this
foreshadowing I simply can't see any
other possibility the fact that Arthur
will return means that this fight
between meliodas and the demon king
zelgius won't be an
z1 I've seen many people commenting that
Mellie Otis is now way too powerful and
there is no way that the demon king can
ever hope to defeat him we have to
remember that Mellie Otis can't just up
and kill the demon king because the
demon king is using sell Jess's body as
a vessel
so if meliodas chooses to kill him he
will also kill his own brother
we know meliodas hasn't been the best
big brother but i don't think he will go
as far as killing zell drous this means
that meliodas will be forced to hold
back and with the demon king being as
ruthless as he is and with the Endura
coming from the demon realm to help the
demon king it is likely that this fight
will be a very difficult one for
meliodas and the sins but if we think
about it rationally this makes sense it
wouldn't be much fun if millie oldest
was just able to destroy the demon king
easily all on his own and the fact that
we're seeing such heavy foreshadowing
about Arthur and Excalibur indicates
that Arthur probably will be needed in
order to help defeat the demon king or
maybe even some other threat down the
line such as the supreme deity it just
wouldn't make sense for us to have seen
that vision from Hawks mama about the
new king being born and Arthur and
Excalibur being shown to us and it
wouldn't make sense to give us this
whole section about the Lady of the lake
if Arthur wasn't going to play an
important role in the future and since
we know that in the past there was talk
about a seven deadly sins spin-off that
would feature King Arthur as the next
protagonist Arthur's somehow coming back
to life would make this spin-off or
sequel a real possibility now moving on
to the rest of the chapter as the demon
king faces off against meliodas
the demon king says that the environment
is enraged because it doesn't need to
demon kings in this world and here the
demon king is referring to all the
natural disasters that have been taking
place all over Britannia by saying that
this world doesn't need to demon kings
the demon king is acknowledging that
melioidosis power has grown to such an
extent that he can now be considered a
demon king in his own right this is an
important admission by the demon king
because now it is clear that he is not
about to underestimate meliodas and his
power as he has done in the past but
meliodas says that the demon king is
wrong the world doesn't need even one
demon king and all of this needless
death and suffering over thousands of
years
been caused by the demon Kings worthless
quarrel with the supreme deity this is
an interesting statement because we
still don't know what the cause of the
conflict between the demon king and the
supreme deity was but many have
speculated that perhaps the two were
once lovers but they had a falling-out
and this is what led to the bloody holy
wars between the goddess and demon clans
by meliodas calling their conflict are
worthless quarrel he may be suggesting
that this was a lover's quarrel that got
out of control after all love and
heartbreak are both very powerful
motivators Mele Otis's words are not
clear here so we can't know for sure but
let me know down in the comments what
you think was the cause of the quarrel
between the demon king and the supreme
deity do you think that they were lovers
or do you think that the cause of their
conflict was something else entirely
following Mele Otis's impassioned speech
the demon king just scoffs at the idea
that the death and suffering experienced
by so many during the holy war should
concern him in the least he says that
these lives are like a stone or a grain
of sand by the road these lives mean
nothing to him the demon king is so much
more powerful than these other creatures
that he considers them to be lesser
life-forms and completely insignificant
in the grand scheme of things like
insects or grains of sand Mele Otis
states that he used to think this way to
back when he was the leader of the ten
commandments but meeting Elizabeth
changed him and he now understands the
value of life and he can now sympathize
with the struggles and challenges that
every living being has to face as they
go about living their own lives thanks
to Elizabeth and all of his friends
meliodas has experienced love compassion
friendship and so many other emotions
that every living being experiences and
he says that he will throw all of the
feelings of everyone who suffered or
lost their lives because of the holy
wars right in the demon King's faced
with that the epic battle between demon
King's eldest and meliodas finally
begins the two overpowered titans begin
to exchange blows as the environment
goes crazy all around them in the final
panel of the chapter Mele Otis appears
to gain the upper hand as he lands a
solid punch on the demon King's face but
we all know that this punch will not be
the
after the recent events that we
witnessed in the manga and after all
that rolling by naka Basu tsuki we have
to pace ourselves and we can't jump to
any definitive conclusions my own
personal guess is that the fact that the
last two chapters directly referenced
Arthur and Arthurian legend is clear
foreshadowing that Arthur will return in
some capacity and I believe that Mellie
Otis and the others are going to need
his help in order to defeat the demon
king and perhaps eventually the supreme
deity
I predict that Arthur will return with a
huge power up and Mellie Otis and the
sins will work together with Arthur to
fully harness the power of the legendary
sword Excalibur and destroy the demon
king once and for all
then after that we may get the
announcement that an Arthur spin-off of
the seven deadly sins featuring Arthur
as the main protagonist is on the way
I've said this before but as long as
meliodas spawn and the rest of the sins
still make regular appearances in the
potential Arthur spin-off I would be
totally fine with it
I just wouldn't want an Arthur spin-off
where the characters that we love from
the original series like the sins
themselves don't show up at all
but let's be real I will read any
potential spin-off or sequel regardless
I just don't want to say goodbye to
meliora spawn Eska nor and all the
others they are such great characters
that I've grown to love and respect let
me know what you guys think about this
whole Arthur thing do you agree with me
that he will come back to life in some
capacity and that Excalibur is going to
play a much bigger role than it has
played so far also how do you think that
the battle between Melly Otis and demon
king zelgius will ultimately unfold well
Mel Yoda's get an easy ko will the demon
king get the better of Melly Otis as a
result of some hidden trick up his
sleeve or will someone else like Arthur
have to join the fray in order to finish
off the demon king let me know down in
the comments I always love hearing from
you if you enjoyed the seven deadly sins
content on this channel you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you have it to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell also don't forget
to check out our brand new Bond love the
pain and Eskin or all hailed the one
shirts on anime out Broadcom a huge
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for supporting our work I want
to give a special thank you to our pro
hero tier page
trends including the one and only
Gilgamesh chubs is the man and nothing
but a fan and another huge thank you to
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
baby ray ace
Ingrid ah a lowland Adam Maddy Mac and
Michael called that on if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
uproar patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]